Hello and welcome to this video on importing assets.
For this we're going to be going over the different ways that we can get assets into
Unreal Engine.
Well, there are multiple different ways to get assets into Unreal Engine and we're not
going to be going over each of them in depth.
We'll only do the main ones but I'll just mention them here so that you are aware of
them for future research.
So first of all there's manual importing and we're going to be demonstrating this with
an FBX former file that you might get from Blender or Maya or some other software.
Also there is the fab integration.
Fab is our asset and art store.
This has a ton of different assets available in it and Unreal is heavily integrated into
it.
So it's really straightforward to buy assets or get assets from the store and then just
import them directly into projects.
Datasmith.
Now Datasmith we will not be going over in this.
Datasmith is a tool designed for primarily people like architects where rather than importing
in a singular asset such as a car or a character or something you would import an entire scene
and you'd want to be able to keep the settings of the scene like where all the lights are
and where all the different assets are placed in their transforms.
So it's really useful for workflow where you're building your scenes in another asset and
you want to import them into Unreal.
We'll be touching on migration and just as a concept really but if you want to move files
between projects, migration allows you to move them across and keep all of the references
intact so that they work when you when you've imported.
Finally Quixel.
Quixel is a service that we have where we have photo, geometry, high res models and
textures.
Now these are all pretty much integrated now with the fab store.
However, before we do this, let's talk about something that's called plugins.
Now plugins are a method of adding things to a project.
Now when you set up a project and you pick a template, a number of different plugins
are automatically going to be enabled and placed into that project.
Now there are a bunch which are very, very standard and there are a bunch that are a
lot more niche.
Unreal has a ton of different plugins that are available, but you can also get lots of
other plugins from the stores or you can create your own plugins in order as a method
to easily transfer things between projects.
So let's jump into the engine here and see how you might go about adding a plugin to
a project.
If I was to come up to the edit window, you can see at the bottom here we have an option
for plugins.
If I click on that, it's going to give me a list of all of the different plugins which
are available in your version of the engine.
Now some of them will be selected and ticked on as you can see here.
However, there are a ton more which are not selected.
Now if I was, for example, to type in Niagara, Niagara is our article system which has a
whole load of different great elements that are part of it.
You can see that there are a load of plugins which are specific to Niagara.
Niagara itself is usually turned on by default, it's used a lot in the engine.
There is also one here called Niagara Fluids.
If I was to tick that, it would warn me that this is in a beta version.
Now what Unreal will do is they will release all of the plugins and all of the different
functionality usually first in a beta version.
Don't let beta turn you off too much because you're going to find that a lot of the engine
is perpetually in beta.
A hell of a lot of this is stuff that we're already shipping in games such as Fortnite.
So don't just ignore things because they're in the beta.
I'm going to click Yes and at the bottom here it's going to ask me to restart.
So I will restart and now this is restarted back up.
I'm going to close this down.
It took me a little bit of time to find it but I've navigated to the plugin Niagara
Fluid content.
It's got a couple of templates here.
So I'm going to drag this into the world.
Now you can now see that we have a fluid simulation going on inside the world.
Now I was just giving this as a demonstration of how you can use a plugin in order to get
extra functionality or to add in different assets into your C.
That's just one of the examples that come with it.
Now you may find in the Fudge Store when we come to that that there will be asset packs
which are offered as plugins.
And what it will allow you to do is download them and add them to your engine version and
then they will be available in the list of plugins.
Next up we have add feature or content pack.
Now this is useful because all of the different templates have different features and content
packs and these are available to be added to any other project.
So let me show you.
So at the moment we are in the third person template.
Now the third person template doesn't have any guns in it.
They say I wanted to bring in a gun.
I know that one exists in the first person.
If I come up to add and come up to add feature or content pack you can now see that I could
come over to the first person template and I could add this to the project.
We have a couple other options as well.
Here is the start of content.
If you didn't select the start of content at the beginning you always add it to a project
here.
If I add the first person add to the project.
So it's going to import the directory for the first person.
Now you can see I've got the first person as a directory and inside of the blueprints
we have my search for weapon.
You can see that we now have a whole load of different options when it comes to weapons.
So for example I've got the grenade launcher.
I can just drag into the scene.
That's going to bring that.
It will also bring everything else that comes with it.
So we'll have a whole load of combinations that can be used for shooting and a whole
load of other special effects that are specific to the first person.
Our next option is to add content and add.
Now add is our store and I'm just going to show you quickly how you would go about adding
the content.
Now I'm back in the epic launcher and if you scroll down at the bottom of it you're going
to find something that says fablib.
These are all of the different tracks that I have acquired from the fab store over the
years.
If I click to visit the fab store it's going to bring me to a store that looks like this.
Now I have connected this to my epic account and at any point I can now come in here and
I can purchase or search for stuff.
You'll find that we don't just offer for Unreal Engine but we also offer it for Unity and Unreal
Editor for Fortnite.
Everything is broken down like you do in a standard asset shop.
You can see things by categories or by specific channels.
Now you'll find that at any one point we usually have a number of assets for free.
At the moment we have the warehouse environment, where Wolf and the spine plug-in that could
all be purchased for free.
These are already in my library as you can see.
However, there are a ton of stuff that is permanently free on here and so if I was to
come into Unreal Engine, verify the look for 3D models.
I can sort by price.
I can just select free.
This is going to provide me with a whole load of free assets.
Now these are permanently free.
Some of them are from Epic but there are a ton of them here.
So it's a great place to start.
Once you've purchased one of these, once you've grabbed one, you've chosen, you've
added it to your library, you'll then find that it appears within the launcher.
So once you've purchased it and it shows up in your launcher, you can refresh to get
any new items that are coming in.
There is going to be a list that looks something like this.
Now you'll notice that on these yellow buttons, there are a couple of different options.
There is either the add to a project, there is create a project, or there is install into
the engine.
Now if, for example, something that requires creating a project, this needs to create its
own project, you'll then need to migrate the assets that you want over into the project
that you're looking at.
We'll show you quickly how to do that.
But if it says add to a project, so for example, I have a blank and a dash of the effects in
this one, this is compatible with our version of the engine.
I'm going to select add to a project, like in first project, add to the project.
And you can see that it is going to add it in here.
Now bear in mind, if you can see that it has this little yellow element here, that means
it's downloaded onto your computer.
You can see that my entire FAB library is 58 dig.
So you have to be careful.
If you don't want one, you can just remove the local content, but it can get big.
So now that I've imported it, you can see that we have a blank and dash of the effects.
If I jump in here, I can add the effect to the level.
Yeah, see that effect is already there.
So it's as quick as that.
You can just really quickly just add in effects from the store.
Just a question of downloading it and dragging it in and all of the assets of that.
That brings us to the end of our first session on importing assets.
Next up, we're going to go over the other methods you can use.